Complete this statement using
less than or greater than--
that's what those symbols
are-- for this kind of
brackets there.
So all they're asking is they
have a 5 and they have a 2,
and they want us to put either
a less than sign for these
brackets or a greater
than sign.
So we just have a 5 and
a 2, and we're just
comparing the two.
Which number is greater?
Well, 5 is greater.
If you count to 5, you're
going to pass up 2.
If you look at a number line
here, if you started at 0, 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, you see that
2 comes before 5.
2 is less than 5.
If I have $2, that's less than
$5, or $5 is greater than $2.
And so the symbol for greater
than, the way you remember
it-- this is probably the
hardest part of how do you
remember it-- is you want the
larger side of the symbol
facing the larger number.
So 5 is the larger number,
so we want the
bigger side of the symbol.
So we want it like this.
The way I think about is that
this right here is the big
side of the symbol, and this
right here, this point, is the
small side of the symbol,
so 5 is greater than 2.
If it was the other way, we
would write 2 is less than 5.
Once again, though, we always
have the point pointing to the
smaller number, and we have the
wide-open part, the big
part of the symbol, pointing
to the larger number.